منذ مقتل الشابه العشرينيه مهسا اميني
وحناجرهم من فكت تصدح بالمراه والحياه
والحريه
مظاهرات واضرابات واعتصامات اسفرت عن مقتل
ما لا يقل عن 300 متظاهر بينهم 47 قاصرا
كما اعتقلت القوات الامنيه قرابه 14000 في
تلك الاضطرابات التي خرجت في 166 مدينه
وبلده
و134 جامعه
[تصفيق]
وعلى واقع القمع اتفق ما يقارب المئه
والعشرين استاذا في جامعه امير كبير
للتكنولوجيا على توجيه رساله لاداره
الجامعه يحذرون فيها من بطش يد الحكومه
التي تتاهب لرفع معيار القسوه في التعامل
مع الانتفاضه الطلابيه بحسب بيان الاساتذه
واكدوا ان لجوء السلطات لهذا الخيار ما هو
الا اسلوب وحشيه يخالف المصلحه العامه
ويؤجج لهيب الغضب في حين وقع 600 من
الكادر التعليميه في البلاد على بيان
يطالب بالغاء جميع الاوامر التي صدرت ضد
الحقوق المدنيه للتلاميذ اضافه الى ضروره
الافراج الفوري بلا قيد او شرط عن مئات
المعتقلين مشددين على اهميه وقف اخذ
تعهدات من الطلاب وتهديد ذويهم
وبينما يطالب ما يزيد عن 200 برلماني
ايراني القضاء باعدام المتظاهرين بعث اصغر
ناظم زاده المرجع الديني والمدرس في حوزه
قم رساله للنواب
تضمنتقادا لصمطهم تجاه القمع اكد فيها ان
الاستقاله خيار افضل من صرف الاموال على
رواتبهم مسؤولين
[موسيقى]
تحت قبه البرلمان انتقاد وحيد وشديد
اللهجه من مندوب مدينه جبهار لتعامل
القوات الامنيه مع المتظاهرين
انتقاد لم تتحمله السلطات فقررت ايقافك
كلمته وتعطيل مكبر الصوت